let's get the initial thoughts of our
panel then on the challenges and
opportunities now facing humankind and
if I can start with you David Miliband
challenges certainly are there any
opportunities in your book yes there are
always opportunities because the world
has more resources than at any time in
human history to tackle the problems and
address the opportunities of a connected
world I think the central lesson of the
Cova crisis is that our connected world
suffers from disconnected government and
the holes in the global safety net that
we've seen both in the advanced
industrialized countries but also in the
developing world I think point to the
areas where we will find solutions I
agree with Niall Ferguson that this is
not a short-term crisis it's a
short-term it's a medium to long term
change in the way we run the planet and
it's incumbent on leaders in business in
NGOs but also in government to rise to
the challenge well we're going to get
into a lot more of that during the
course of this hour so Mary Robinson
some people are saying business as usual
is the best we can hope for is that
setting the bar too low very much so yes
business as usual wasn't bringing us to
a good place because we were heading for
a climate crisis we were not taking
seriously so I think we can learn a lot
from the terrible sudden dramatic
downturn of kovat 19 it has upset our
world it has cost lives it has cost
livelihoods it is not equal it's not a
great leveler it's actually a
exacerbated all the inequalities but it
has taught us a few important lessons
first of all that human behavior
generally matters that's what's
protecting us from the virus it's the
collective behavior of people complying
with the lockdown with the social
distancing with the hand-washing etc
secondly science matters thankfully
we've been listening to the health
experts we were not listening enough to
the climate scientists
to the intergovernmental panel on
climate change which told us in October
2018 we had to reduce by 45 percent
carbon emissions by 2030 to have any
chance of a future for our children and
grandchildren think of it and we were
not listening so the other thing is
government matters that's really very
interesting and if I may since I'm the
only woman on this program just to say
it's actually interesting that women LED
governments have done well we've had
Angela Merkel in in in Germany we've had
the Prime Minister's of Norway Denmark
Iceland Finland we've had Jacinda Iran
it was briefly on your screen in New
Zealand we've had the President of
Thailand
all of them took tough decisions quickly
for their people and then brought their
population along with them in a way that
was important and so government matters
and then the last thing I would say is
compassion matters and this I think is
something that would be you know really
very important going forward we need to
have an empathy for the suffering of
others we need to have a solidarity with
the suffering of others and I've no
doubt that this is something that would
greatly appeal in many ways you know to
what in particular what David Miliband
was saying we need to care okay well
Mary Robertson an awful lot we're going
to expand on that during the course of
the hour as they say but Neil focus and
want to get your sense of what history
tells us about a a global crisis like
this is being an impetus for change I'm
not sure that it's necessarily I was a
an impetus for the kind of change that
you might want historically pandemics
have been disruptive of international as
well as domestic order indeed it was one
of the striking features of the history
of ancient Rome that that pandemics
posed almost as big as threat to the
stability of the empires as invading
barbarians I think it's important to
take a long hard look at
happened to our international order when
this pandemic arose I'm grant very glad
I'm ambassador Lewis on this show
because let's face it China has some
very difficult questions to answer about
what happened in Wuhan back in December
and in the early part of January there
is very compelling evidence to suggest
that China reacted much too slowly and
took far too long to recognize and admit
the extent of the problem in Hebei
Province indeed acted far too late in
imposing a ban on travel from Hebei only
On January 23rd
more than three weeks after it was clear
that was something very seriously wrong
so I think the first question that we
need to address is the future
relationship really between the western
China the second point I think that that
needs to be addressed is whether
globalization is now really over as a
phenomenon it's been in crisis really
since 2008 the financial crisis and this
is dealt another blow to the whole
notion of international supply chains
extending all around the world and
increasing the dependency of economies
on each other the fact that the United
States is so reliant on China the pharma
pharmaceuticals came as quite a shock to
people in the US and finally it's a
striking thing that Mary Robinson didn't
mention the most successful female
leader of all which is president Tsai of
Taiwan the country that actually
probably handled the pandemic most
successfully despite being in very close
proximity to the People's Republic of
China and our end by observing that
Taiwan is probably potentially an even
bigger flashpoint in the international
order than Hong Kong as relations
between the United States and China
deteriorate it's been a really striking
feature of this year that's what I call
cold war to last year seems only to have
intensified in the face of the pandemic
we're going to tease out a lot of these
issues as I say we've got in television
terms quite a long time to discuss all
this so ambassador I want to start with
you by asking you because of the
questions posed by Neil fair
and so many others around the world
about China's role first of all in
coronavirus and not telling the world
about it soon enough and perhaps not
reacting soon enough I'm sure you may
disagree with that but the overall
question is just China there forever
have a special responsibility to the
world to improve it to try to make
things better now I think there's a lot
of debate these days about what the
consequences of is pandemic whether the
pandemic will unite the world or make
the world more divided I tend to believe
it made the world more United
I think this pandemic really shows us
again that we all belongs to this global
village just as a presidency said you
know we should all try to build this a
shared a community of shared future for
mankind
I think this endemic show us that
international community should cooperate
you know I can it shows that those
countries who supported you that each
other who support w-h-o play a leading
role who support multilateralism and and
who support a who listened to the advice
of a [ __ ] Oh have able to put the
barriers and the control and those
countries who reject International
Cooperation who reject WHL advice has
paid high price and I think no country
no matter how strong you are you cannot
be immune you cannot be ice in selecting
from this pandemic ok berries with
berries respect no trace I've got some
you know I'm going to kind of cost you
because we do have an awful lot of time
to to discuss these issues I wanted you
all to set out your stalls you're
talking about global cooperation will be
testing China's commitment to that
during the course of the evening because
I want to bring in the first question
from our virtual audience first up is
Louis Carmichael from London very good
to hear from you Louie
can you please pose your question to our
panel thank you damn it yes good evening
and everybody I'd like to return to mr.
Ferguson's kind of first point and I'd
like to kind of know what kind of global
fallout might we expect after co vid
once investigations are underway and
questions start to be asked of
nation-states particularly China in the
US
okay well knew you wanted to put that
first then sir Neil Ferguson professor
Ferguson then Louis asked what kind of
global fallout might occur after this so
we in a delicate situation I think we
are I mean I think one has to recognize
that the World Health Organization
didn't exactly cover itself in glory
back in January took far too long to
acknowledge the seriousness of the
crisis and I think there are legitimate
questions to be asked about its
closeness to the government in Beijing
but I don't want to give the impression
that the fault in tally lies with China
I think all the really big entities in
the world have in their different ways
performed badly there are clearly
disorder diseconomies of scale because
the United States grotesquely mishandled
the crisis dithering around through
January February and into March and
leaving it far too late to take the kind
of actions that had been very successful
in countries such as Taiwan and South
Korea and the European Union did rather
poorly as an institution in the first
phase of the crisis though things have
somewhat improved since then there was a
distinct atmosphere of so Cooper back in
January in February when it seemed for a
time that the Germans weren't even going
to allow the export of emergency medical
supplies to Italy so I think it's very
interesting to see how the big players
in the international order have
underperformed
and also that some of the international
institutions like the w-h-o didn't
really do the job that was expected of
them I think the small players actually
come out as having performed best if you
look at a league table of countries that
handled the crisis really well I've
mentioned Taiwan it's very near the top
at new zealand and it should also be
said australia have coped much better
than other english-speaking countries we
could mention Israel has done notably
well and it begins to look as if small
is beautiful in in the sense that if
you're trying to cope with the crisis of
the sort that we've just seen having a
really efficient pandemic preparedness
plan that actually works that means
large-scale testing early on and contact
tracing this seems to have come much
more easily to these small nimble
countries especially those like Taiwan
and Israel that know they're in an
insecure environment so I think that's
one important lessons to take away from
this that in some ways it's been a great
advert for small small town governments
and not big ones okay well let's talk a
bit about the smaller ones and the big
ones with David Miliband and David
Miliband just to get it back to Louise
question he's worried all wants to know
what you see as being the potential
global fallout from all this now of
course the ambassador ambassador Liu's
been telling us well it's going to be
global cooperation does it really look
that rosy to you well I think that
Louise question needs a historical
perspective my thought that Niall
Ferguson would have said that we have
some historical parallels we know that
after 1918 a world which retreated
behind its walls in which nationalism
took root ended in disaster we also have
a counter example after 1945 when the
rights of individuals were put alongside
the rights of states as the foundation
of the international system and produced
despite the cold war a long period of
growing peace and prosperity although
there were plenty of outbreaks of
conflict and poverty amongst them but
the general trend was towards peace and
prosperity
I think what's striking about this
crisis is that all the big players may
indeed lose I think it's not been a good
crisis for China but it's not been a
crisis for the United States either and
the great danger for those of us who are
neither Chinese nor American is that the
two big powers retreat into at best
firing volleys of rhetoric at each other
at worst take risks with Security and
Prosperity whether on Taiwan or on trade
and that leaves the rest of the world
feeling that it there is no rudder on
the global boat and I think that that is
a very worrying prospect the Israeli
author Yuval Harare has talked about the
dangers of thinking about the world as
networks of fortresses and I think that
in a connected world that vision is a
very dangerous one it's one that
promises impoverishment for those who
are left behind and also really dark
conflicts whether in cyberspace or
elsewhere so I think that Louise
question is right to raise the specter
of a very dangerous standoff and I don't
think it should be in anyone's interest
to fuel that okay well on Louise
question as well the other part of it I
want to put this to the ambassador he
says once investigations are underway
well a core question then to China is is
some does China except it's its
culpability its responsibilities during
this crisis and and will it let me ask
you straight up will it allow
investigators independent investigators
onto Chinese soil to work out what
happened yeah we certainly welcome our
international review by the purpose is
not to label any country or countries
that closely covered by the Burroughs
should be accountable you know we
support and together with a
hundred-twenty
member state during a new Health
Assembly that had a proper time it is
necessary as any a major pandemic that
it's not worth of international
community to carry out you know review
the purpose to sum up experience to get
a pair better for the future pandemic
and like this review first should be
independent and should be paid
dependence women is to be free from
politicization should be based on
science you know they should like the
scientists to take the lead sorry to
interrupt ambassador but but who would
you accept then leading it
you have to deem it to be in the blade
and who would you like to see overseeing
it independent review in all countries
should cat amore especially the major
players as I mentioned can I have a few
moment you know I can't I buy
differences with Neil you know one he
blame China post slow reaction that's
not true I think Neil got a lot of wrong
information including the one when he
said the China one one was at a long
time and no flights came coming out from
one but still many flights go into other
countries no not true that's not true
that's a fort information in one who Han
was locked up no flights at all starting
from 23rd of January no no flights no
trains not at all so with regard to how
China react to this pandemic China was
the first country to report to the
deputy pho first identify the person and
first to share the genetic sequence with
whu-oh and other countries China with no
time to share information to share each
and containing the virus okay Mary
Robinson are we having towards this
cooperation you've all been talking
about it and hoping for or isn't the
reality that this is fragmenting the
world that nations are turning inward
that nation-states and indeed as neil
ferguson we're saying many of those
smaller nations that really aren't part
of part of bigger operations have done
better during the crisis isn't that then
setting the tone for what the future
looks like
i think it's true that countries
understandably want to protect their
populations
yes the immediate thing is what does it
take to protect my country my people to
get the ventilators the PPE
etc but we're actually seeing two things
I think we're seeing certainly at the
European Union level a very significant
move on the green New Deal and on
biodiversity and I welcome both because
green new deal on its own won't get us
there the fund for just transition all
of this is new thinking that is going to
shape our future we need to come out of
covert 19 understanding the way we will
align with dealing with the climate
crisis we must not go back to business
as usual it was not taking us in the
right direction and it was also
symptomatic of terribly inequalities and
I think you know as people are locked in
their home they're thinking of their
families of their loved ones of their
neighbors and they're thinking of us as
a human as a humanity that is very
fragile and needs to work together I'm
actually a bit distressed by the
conversation we're hearing because it's
it's kind of political scoring goals as
Deborah I'm not into that I think we
actually need more than ever to move
because we have this utter crisis which
is still the most important and worst
crisis the climate crisis so we are not
in a comfortable place coming out of
covert 19 we have to work together as a
global community we can't do it on our
own okay right well I want to get some
of our audience's reaction to what we've
been hearing so far so can I ask you
panelists how many of you think that
China should shoulder most of the blame
for the pandemic and second question
we'll get on to that in a moment or two
about the international system first
question how many of you think China
just a show of hands should shoulder
most of the blame for the pandemic
I'd say that's just under half of you've
got a second question how many of you
then think it was a failure of the
international system more generally how
many of you think it was a failure of
the international system more generally
let's get your hands up please
well three similar number may be
slightly more okay we'll hold that
thought so we'll get our panelists view
on it in a moment or two but we've got
time now for another audience question
let's bring in Ayman daily who's in
London Ayman what would you like to ask
this evening good evening Dermot and
panelists post pandemic does the panel
see an urgent need for reform of global
institutions such as the UN World Health
Organization and the European Union or
are we likely to see an increased
fragmentation between member state
participants okay man thank you for that
that's really feeds into that question I
asked about who our audience think have
shouldered most of the blame for the
pandemic and the reaction there David
Miliband I'm not sure if you could see
it or not was there too many I think
more people thought it was a failure of
the international system more generally
therefore to address a man's question do
these huge global institutions that have
been around for so many years and let's
put the front two in the frame they're
the United Nations and part of that the
World Health Organization are the only
longer fit for purpose well the World
Health Organization is obviously part of
the United Nations and I think Amon is
absolutely right to say that we should
start there we're living in a world
where three billion people have no
access to running water in their own
home we're in a living in a world where
80% of fragile states war-torn States
around the world are off track to meet
the sustainable development goals that
aim to eliminate poverty by 2030 and I
think that health provides us with the
opportunity to build something better to
build something different not just go
back to a failing business as usual what
does that mean in terms of health and
put three things on the table straight
away first of all we need a better
a more independent World Health
Organization the truth is its weaknesses
reflect the factors tied down by its
membership structure it needs to be more
independent secondly we need a better
funding and more independently funded
well health organization so that it's
able to carry out its work without
worrying what the member states who fund
it will say and thirdly and I think
critically we need a world health
organization that is more powerful that
is able to do independent inspections
its able to partner with the private
sector more effectively as well as with
NGOs and I think if we can get the
reform of the World Health Organization
right it could set a template for a
wider set of institutions that also need
to be got right
it's the holes in the safety net that
the World Health Organization needs to
tackle but it needs to be more
independent better funded and more
powerful to be able to do so and
obviously that is not compatible with
the kind of withdrawal doctrine that
we're seeing from the US at the moment
indeed and we'll get onto that in a
moment but Mary Robinson
so David Miliband points out the w-h-o
of course an arm of the United Nations
so more generally does the same really
apply to the United Nations in terms of
David Miliband prescription there I very
much agree with what David was saying
and of course the UN needs reform I used
to say when I served as UN High
Commissioner for Human Rights quoting
Winston Churchill on democracy it's the
worst system except for all the others
we don't have any other and if we didn't
have the UN we would have to reinvent it
quickly because the world would fall
apart in so many different ways but this
is an opportunity and I think that's
really what I hoped we could talk about
and we need now to understand that
covert 19 which nobody would have wished
on the world it is terrible it's unequal
it's exacerbating inequalities it's
deadly but it has broken a
business-as-usual which was not bringing
us to a safe world we have to remember
that was not bringing us to a safe world
so how do we come out of this and we are
seeing now much more thought we're
seeing opinion polls where the climate
crisis at last is very high on people's
agenda
we are seeing the IMF saying stop
support for fossil fuel subsidies we're
seeing investment the big investment
community saying align your investment
to the Paris principles and we're seeing
a big move in the business community
we're seeing young people school
children and young people saying and we
want you to listen to the science don't
listen to us we're only children listen
to the science all of this to me means
we have to come out of this in a much
much better more coordinated way that
does understand that the limits of the
multilateral system but also the
importance of us reform though the
existing institutions near Ferguson and
given that analysis of the w-h-o and how
its performed during this crisis
President Trump have a point it's in
China's pocket and he's right to
withdraw its funding by the United
States well I can't agree with President
Trump on this because withdrawing the
United States only increases the
probability that the w-h-o will become
but holding to China or one of the other
great powers because let's not kid
ourselves with all due respect my old
friend David Miliband the international
order set up after World War 2 was
designed to be dominated by the great
pass that's why there are five permanent
members of the UN Security Council and
we shouldn't kid ourselves about some
magical time of liberal paradise because
for most of the period after the 1940s
we had a cold war two super bars duked
it out using the Security Council mostly
to block one another that that era came
to an end of course with the collapse of
the Soviet Union and we had a kind of
interregnum a period of US dominance
that has now clearly come to an end and
we seem to be back to Cold War only this
time it's China in the role of the
Soviet Union and I have to take issue
with something Mary Robinson said a
moment ago
it is not politicization to ask for
clear answers from China to the question
what happened in December January we
need to know we still don't know where
this Corona
virus first made the jump to humans
except that it was in Wuhan but whether
it was in a wet market or a laboratory
we still do not know and to respond to
something ambassador Liu said the
reality and it's clear for multiple
scientific papers including papers
published by Chinese scientists is that
this virus was exported to the rest of
the world from China in Malta through
multiple airports in the course of
January and although flights out of
Wuhan were restricted on the 23rd
flights continued from all the other
Chinese airports and they clearly
transported the virus to Europe as well
as to the United States and other
countries so I don't think it's
politicization to say that we need to
understand what went wrong just in the
same way that we needed to understand
what went wrong when the Chernobyl
nuclear power station blew up
unfortunately one party states have
rather a bad track record of
precipitating enormous disasters and the
more power that those kind of countries
have in the international system I'm
afraid the less the international system
is really fit for purpose so I think my
form is urgently needed and withdrawals
not the answer but we must emphasize
China's role in all this and I was glad
to see that what a lie cannot narrow
majority of your panel agreed with me
yeah well we've got this is you referred
to we've got the Ambassador here so
let's put some of those points to him
and centrally you know the central
charge there from Neil Ferguson you said
that there were no flights out of Wuhan
during the build-up and during the
pandemic but of course there were plenty
of flights there were hundreds of
flights out of China as a whole and the
virus surely started circulating in the
world like that now you've got to admit
that having you before the world is
going to take you seriously I think he's
amazing he's totally wrong and I said
earlier that one we have a woman putting
locked up there's no flight at all no
connection with outside of work I'm very
sorry
actually here so many Cold War directrix
from Manu you know we can that we know
each other
before but I don't know why you know he
is so interesting having a cold war with
the China I just want to let you know
China is not a formal Soviet Union
you being a historic unit should have a
serious study of China you know I want
to put inside I can provide you with
more information more fact we have visit
24 reality check our mail it to you I
just want to say we shouldn't talk to
the law played by Rachel we shouldn't
because tablet it's all spoke positively
about efforts of China
you know wh0 is a very important
international organization with a bus
and retread sorry I just have to bring
you back to the Chinese responsibility
undoubtedly and we know this that China
was in denial about kovat 19 for so long
about animal to human transmission about
human to human transition you didn't
tell the world soon enough I told you we
lost no time in forming from you know
this is a new various you have to be
responsible you know it's unknown to all
of us so in whoa you will need
scientists to study in the responsible
way and seriously once we like think we
identify this new where is 12 days after
the first report then we immediately
report to the WTO and share this
information whether countries relevant
countries there's no cover there's no
delay China's record is a three it can
stand the test of time and a history
also saying China first report the
barest it does not mean the virus
originated from China in terms of origin
I think is up to the scientists to
decide because as a situation unfold we
read many reports that some cases much
earlier than China's first reports okay
like the United States Italy you know we
need to adopt scientific approach what
this
matter what about that question though
then about reform of the World Health
Organization China would accept that yes
of course you know from this pandemic it
shows the wickedness of
w-h-o you know both in terms of basic
capability also intended in terms of its
resources and also how whu-oh could
respond more quickly more effectively
especially taking care of the poorest
marking the weak countries I think this
is a reform but you know we can do this
after we claim the final victory of the
various that top priority right now is
to put together is to support the
International to support a try to lead
we are still we have not yet this virus
under control yeah okay but you would
support a reformed well health
organization right we're talking of
course about the pandemic but that's not
the only issue threatening the world and
it may not even be the most important we
conducted a wide-ranging poll for this
program of what the public thinks about
the future so let's share it with you in
our exclusive survey we asked looking
forward what is the biggest issue that
the world needs to address now take this
in because 33% 1/3 of those polled said
the environment and climate change were
well ahead then of the 15 percent less
than how if we said preventing future
pandemics 14 percent pretty close said
poverty the rise of China as a
superpower was the biggest issue for 11
percent of the people and terrorism was
the main concern for just 3 percent so
the environment there on 33%
well let's sir put that to some of the
palace there and Mary Robinson
that's just what you were saying a
little bit earlier there and our polling
supports that I take a comfort from that
because I think people in their homes
first of all they've seen the air has
cleared up in our cities we can hear the
birds singing and somehow nature has
reasserted itself in a way that people
actually feel emotionally and people
want cities that are there for people
and with public transport cycleways
pedestrianisation etcetera and you know
city planners are beginning to really
get this message that's part of one of
the ways in which we can move out but
actually you know we need to just go
green go green with investment jobs
insulating houses and buildings and also
the biodiversity side the rewilding the
understanding of our link with nature
the the real need for the kind of
support that young people in particular
get that indigenous people have been
telling us about for years there's a lot
of wisdom around if only we'd listened
to it well david miliband
can we join up her to these findings
then that's on the Environment and
climate change and then second place was
those said preventing future pandemics
was most important I mean and does it
tell us what's happened during this
pandemic the reaction to it that people
only take things seriously when they
happen and that's too big a risk of
course to take with climate change well
I think you're making a important point
that because climate change is long-term
because in some ways it's invisible it's
a deadlier threat for governments to try
and come to grips with but I think that
the real striking thing about your poll
to me is how few people mentioned the
global economy I think in six months
time there's going to be a lot of people
who are worried about global recession
and here's the thing some people will
tell you that that is a reason to ignore
the environment I would say that the
drive for low carbon living the drive to
live as if there is one planet not three
was at the moment we're three times
exhausting the potential of the planet
that drive for a low-carbon economy will
be the great economic regenerator over
the next 20 years if it's organized
properly and this debate about whether
or not there's a choice between
addressing the existential or the
generational challenge of climate change
on the other hand addressing what I
believe will be very very severe
economic consequences of the crisis the
fallout in developed countries but also
the fallout in developing countries I
think that it's absolutely key that we
see these two problems together and it's
only by addressing them together that I
think we have a chance of addressing
both of them that's true whether you're
Chinese whether you're British or
American but also whether you're one of
the billion people living in Africa
okay plenty more to discuss on that
because the environment is also the
subject of our next question from our
virtual audience and Sara Lee who is in
Surrey Sara what would you like to ask
this evening well thank you very much
dammit and good evening my question is
during the condom pandemic we have seen
a drastic fall in emissions how can the
world sustain that success by lowering
their emissions from public transport
shipping and air traffic good question
thank you very much indeed Sara well let
me put that to one of the world's
biggest emitters of co2 that is of
course China and the Chinese ambassador
to the United Kingdom lujo Ming who say
whether some what is China's commitment
then to keeping up this temporary fall
in emissions China is very much
committed to Paris agreement you know
China have completed its obligations
three years ahead in 2018 we have
brought down the carbon intensity 45%
from 2005 and also that we have also
brought down the the consumption of the
the carbon units per GDP by 2% and China
now is the largest investor in new
energy in you know the usable energy and
China is a very committee a to climate
change China is supposed to hold
conference by the end of the year
biological convention conference tell
her you know what I mean
is it going to go ahead that you're
still planning to do it the date has not
yet been finalized yet because of these
endemic so it's still open this year
supposed to be a year of collaboration
of China okay in environment
environmental protection and now you
okay have we scheduled your called 26 to
max yeah
November but we are still kept a very
close contact online with my British
colleagues compare note how to make
conferences great success Neil Ferguson
do we need a reality check on all this
for at least this century and certainly
before that we've been hearing all these
words of encouragement on climate change
but people keep asking in reality where
is the oversight where's the the
sanction for the transgresses well
that's that's a good question actually
because there isn't one I walked out the
other day that China was responsible for
about sixty percent of all the increase
in co2 emissions since the birth of
Greta tunberg and if you look at China's
current energy policy it entails
building roughly one coal fueled power
station a week in fact one sign of
China's very rapid return to economic
normality is precisely the increased
consumption of coal which we can measure
and is now above levels last year so I
think one has to with all due respect
sir ambassador de leur acknowledged that
fundamentally the ongoing problem are of
co2 emissions has much more to do with
China as well as with India and some
middle eastern countries that it has to
do with Europe or North America where
emissions really are declining the other
thing I'd say by way of a reality check
and this goes right to the question that
misses
asked is that as we acknowledge the
birdsong around the cities and marvel at
the clear skies I hope we're going to
realize that this reveals the trade off
yeah we have reduce co2 emissions and
the skies have been clear over some very
industrialized parts of the world in the
early part of this year but the
economies have collapsed unemployment in
the United States will probably reach
great depression levels when the new
number is announced this week the
collapse of economy economic output in
all the major economies of the world is
as bad as anything since the early 1930s
and this illustrates pretty clearly that
there's a trade-off that you can't
actually drastically reduce emissions in
the way that Greta tun Berg calls for at
the World Economic Forum back in January
without some significant losses in
employment and economic activity it's
it's just central to our whole
discussion that we recognize that these
priorities that you ask people about in
your poll are interdependent you can't
just focus on one at the World Economic
Forum in January all people wanted to
talk about was climate change and when I
said look you should be much more
worried about the approaching pandemic
people gave me rather funny looks if you
focus only on one of the issues if you
constantly emphasize the importance of
climate change
you become myopic and you start to miss
the other threats they're actually in
some ways much more imminence than than
the threat of climate change so the true
answer to your poll actually is all of
the above we can't just focus on one of
these things and they're interdependent
certainly what's a reality check there
we've got plenty of questions flooding
in so let's get on to them another
question from our audience
Amanda Holland is in Hampshire hello
there Amanda what would you like to ask
good evening Dermot and so I'd like to
ask the Chinese ambassador principally
this pandemic is a threat to the human
race not just to an individual nation
though there's not in positions of power
I feel mistrust towards world leaders
how do the government's plan to work
together better to protect the human
race during world crises and rebuild
that trust
okay rebuilding trust is the core of
Amanda's question but I also want to add
into that
we asked about public trust in that
exclusive after the pandemic poll that
we've carried out let's show you that we
asked whether the corona virus outbreak
has improved or damaged the
international standing of certain
countries and here's of some of the
findings three percent of those surveyed
said China had improved its reputation
more than three-quarters said it had
damaged its just 1% though said the
United States had improved its standing
versus 68 percent he said the United
States had damaged it let's have a look
at the United Kingdom and our survey
found that six percent of people thought
the country's reputation had been
improved forty-three percent thought it
had been damaged well straight to our
panelists David Miliband let's talk
about Britain first reputation clearly
damaged their have as have so many other
countries but what do you see as the the
core mistakes made by the United Kingdom
I think the most important thing to
recognize is that people are pretty
smart because that seems to me to be a
very clear verdict on all three
countries where there were delays in all
three countries at the beginning in
coming to terms with the crisis and then
in the US and the UK a really faltering
response I think that there are three
elements really to this we know if you
don't get your testing going then you
don't know where the disease is if you
don't get your tracing going right then
you're not able to ensure that those who
do have the disease are isolated and if
you don't get your public information
your public trust that the question are
referred to right then your
communications it doesn't achieve the
goals that are set and so I think for
the UK now at a very delicate a very
difficult position the priorities must
be to get a testing system that people
can believe in because that's absolutely
core to any kind of release from the
lockdown and we know that from other
countries you've also got to get your
contact tracing right I work for an
international non-governmental
organisation working in war-torn
countries we know there too testing is
not not enough tracing is not enough
they're the absolute foundation of them
the public trust that is essential
well I'm basa delue part of Amanda's
question was directly she said address
at China and I want to ask you
specifically about rebuilding trust
about the the race to develop a vaccine
for Kovach 19 and we know the advances
that China indeed so many other
countries are making but if China were
to develop an effective vaccine would it
be willing and this is in terms of
rebuilding trust I suppose would it be
willing to share that vaccine with the
planet as cheaply as possible
absolutely you know President Xi made
firm commitment during a wh World Health
Assembly that you know once the vaccine
is available
China wants to make it a public good
make it especially accessible available
to developing countries China now is
among the most advanced countries in
terms of vaccine research and now we are
in a phase - we already have five
clinical trials but we want to share
with the rest of the world in fact China
is also working with the UK with other
countries including United States the
scientists on the vaccine I I think they
I can't agree with the table you just
show that China reputation has been
damaged it should be depends on where
you get this information according to
the information I have is by the Adelman
the independent PR company of United
States they have this world parameter
2020 China enjoying the highest fat we
support amongst people
it's about 82 percent fall among
countries and also according to the
Singapore you know a public opinion
company black box research they have at
the review a survey of 23 countries
China again so the rest of the 23 the
Chinese government enjoy okay more than
80 fight the public support okay well
I'm gonna see if I'm gonna tear the
support of our audience want to see what
they feel about their the question of
trust now so let's
turn to you panel I get your arms ready
again raise your hands here's the
question if you trust your government to
do the right thing wherever you are do
you trust your government to do the
right thing
Wow so about four five hands in total
there what's that about 10% of you okay
how many of you trust Donald Trump to
work with other countries to build a
better future Donald Trump how many of
you trust Donald Trump to work with
other countries to build a better future
well and lots of shaking heads and no
hands raised what about the Chinese
government same question what do you
think about the Chinese government its
ability to work with other countries to
build a better future well perhaps a
dozen of you or so so reaction from our
panelists I want to go to you Mary
Robinson because talking about the
erosion of trust I mean quite telling
there wasn't it there and particularly
on that question about people's trust in
their own governments as I say about 10%
of our panelists felt any trust in them
whatsoever is part of this and you've
been referring it to it throughout the
course of the evening is it a
generational divide where we're seeing
it on the streets of so many countries
right at the moment in spite of lockdown
younger generations yeah I think that
there is a very real uneasiness in our
world at the moment because of the
inequality and because of the inequities
and as David Miliband said because of
the kind of awful poverty that a large
proportion of the world live in that is
not acceptable
it's not what we should be doing as a
human race concerned about our fellow
human beings we need to think deeply
during this terrible shock to the system
which as I said has broken a
business-as-usual which wasn't going to
bring us where we need to go because it
was full of inequality and so
how do we actually build back better we
know how we build back better we move
dramatically to green deals green new
green deal
biodiversity nature based solutions
investment that's aligned companies that
are aligned and we do it in a way that
has just transition for the workers in
the coal oil and gas and I would hope
and I make an appeal to the ambassador
of China I hope that China would give us
a leadership out of this that doesn't go
the way of coal
I'm very sorry to hear of new coal
plants in China frankly because you have
an expertise in the wind and solar and
electric vehicles go that route and help
us all to go that route ok well new
focus and go to ask you about the other
part of that polling Donald Trump got no
votes at all in terms of trust to work
with other countries to build a better
future of course a general election
coming a presidential election coming if
that's the feeling and it is among
sections of his of his own country
should he be worried Oh present Trump
has plenty to worry about for an
incumbent to go into an election in the
depths of recession as bad as anything
since the 1930s seems almost like a
doomed Enterprise for an incumbent to go
into an election with their excess
mortality comparable with deaths in the
Vietnam War seems again like a doomed
enterprise in fact if you were to listen
only to the opinions of people in
Western Europe and the UK you would
assume that this election was over that
Trump should simply throw in the towel
the way Lyndon Johnson did in 1968 and
let Joe Biden have the keys to the White
House tomorrow but I think if you take a
closer look in the at the United States
you'll see that this ain't over
true Joe Biden the presumptive
Democratic nominees ahead by about 10
points in a recent national poll but
you'll remember that national polls
weren't a great guide to the 2016
election and I think this great wave of
urban unrest that we're seeing all over
the United States in the past week is is
a reason to keep one's eyes very firmly
on the coming
months it is I think far from over and
indeed I think the writers and
particularly those who engaged in
looting have unwittingly done President
Trump a favor by changing the subject
from covert 19 where he was on a hiding
to nothing to some of the old questions
that have been able to merican politics
for a very long time indeed so I'm
afraid to say that no matter how little
confidence he enjoys amongst your panel
and I don't find that terribly
surprising you'd have got the same
result in Germany by the way I think the
question of how Americans vote come
November the third is still is still
open okay I think it's far from it's far
from over
I'm sorry to cut in because we are
running out of time unbelievable given
the amount of time we've devoted to it
but I've got to ask the the ambassador
finally on this this lack of trust
particularly with younger generations
where you are seeing that on the streets
of Hong Kong and the Chinese states
repression of those protesters those
seekers after democracy no it's not the
Chinese you know suppressant what is
going on in Hong Kong is violence you
know it's a it's totally it's a risk to
the national security you know it's the
perpetrators storm the department the
electrical voice we call it and they
even put on unfair innocent people you
know if the same thing happened in the
street of London if the writers storm
the UK Parliament what will be okay
reaction the UK government police will
sit back and let the things going on I
think any responsible government has to
take measures you know people did not
realize that one country two systems
have achieved great success since Hong
Kong returned to China times yes I am so
terribly sorry we've run out of time I
can hardly believe it first of all I
want to thank everyone in our audience
for your questions and indeed for your
voting thanks for taking part thanks as
well to our panelists David Miliband
Mary Robinson Neil Ferguson ambassador
Lu
very good to talk to you all thank you
very much indeed so tonight we've
learned that China would support an
independent international review of the
outbreak of the pandemic under the
auspices of the World Health
Organization and reform of the w-h-o to
give it more power and we'll have more
world-changing ideas tomorrow evening at
8 o'clock do Jonas then for after the
pandemic our newer